foreign
you may have had the experience of
unboxing furniture
and come across instructions that go
something like this
shelf according to the provided diagram
yes I know what a bookshelf looks like
probably wouldn't be reading the
assembly instructions if I didn't need a
little more help with the process
or maybe you've opened a cookbook with
an author who thinks you're already
somewhat of a chef
deglaze the pan
what
okay off I go on a separate search to
understand whatever that means
instructions that tell you what to do
and not how to do it are pretty useless
and yet even when we're talking about
something as important as climate change
we hear them all the time
transition to renewable energy Electrify
everything else deploy solutions that
are Equitable and fair
yes
let's do all of that
but
how
answering how is where we understand
which Solutions are actually feasible
whether that be with today's
infrastructure or evolving regulatory
environment or any of the other number
of dependencies and constraints that we
have to consider
how we solve climate change also depends
on our very definition of the problem
it's a scientific challenge a
socio-political issue an economic
problem and so much more and how we
solve it will depend on how we frame it
there is no single answer
I'm a scientist so I approach climate
change as a scientific challenge
I'm also a techno-optimist and
artificial intelligence product manager
so I also approach it as a technological
one
when it comes to a sustainable future
artificial intelligence can help us do
three critical things
first it can help us understand climate
change and its effects on Earth's
ecosystems
second it can help us optimize current
systems and infrastructure because we
can't just start over from scratch today
and third it can help us accelerate the
Breakthrough science we need such as
Fusion as a carbon free energy source
today I'd like to talk about that second
one optimizing current systems and
specifically how we can use AI to
harness a superpower we already have in
this fight
wind energy
Renewables are unquestionably a key to a
sustainable future but the problem is
they're unpredictable sometimes the sun
shines and the wind blows and sometimes
it just doesn't
now
for an electricity systems operator who
needs Supply to meet demand in real time
24 7. this is hugely problematic
Renewables can't be 100 reliably
scheduled
now unfortunately fossil fuel plants are
the opposite
you can burn a specific amount of coal
at a set time to deliver exactly the
amount of electricity you want in a
predictable time window
so
if you're a power systems manager whose
job is to literally keep the lights on
which source are you more confident
depending on
but here's one of the places where AI
can come in it is a powerful tool for
forecasting
AI systems can ingest vast amounts of
historical data and help us predict
future events
so while we can't eliminate the
variability of wind we can use AI to
more accurately predict its availability
that was my team's what to do
use AI to accelerate the transition to
Renewables like wind energy
the tough part was the how to do it
first we research the challenge we read
papers we spoke to domain experts we
found out everything we could about the
problem
our team which is a mix of research
scientists engineers product manager
program manager and an impact analyst
decided that a neural net trained on
historical weather data and turbine
power production information would
likely help us accomplish our goal
next
we needed to find two core elements
data to train the system
and a partner who was willing to deploy
it
both of these can be major obstacles
when it comes to deploying AI in real
world scenarios
let's start with data
there are massive gaps in climate
critical data not just in electricity
but in agriculture Transportation
industry and many other sectors
some of our data we could purchase or
download for free weather forecasts for
instance
but some of the data we needed was
proprietary
and this would be like turbine power
production information and other
operational data from the wind farms
now we needed that proprietary data so
that we could train our models to learn
the relationship between historical
weather and historical power production
so it could then make predictions about
future power availability based on what
data said about future weather
now it's probably worth mentioning here
that we were looking at a few years of
data on hourly resolution not historical
data at a time scale that would have
massive climactic differences from
present day in addition to data
we needed to find a partner with domain
expertise and the willingness and scale
to test new systems
you know surprisingly this can be a
major hurdle when it comes to deploying
AI in the real world
believe it or not it's not every Wind
Farm manager that wants to let a bunch
of AI researchers test on their
multi-million or multi-billion dollar
systems
but the thing is in order to prove that
AI works we have to have deployment
opportunities in the real world
luckily for us Google was a ready and
willing partner okay yes deepmind is a
part of Google but it's not a given that
they would let us test on their systems
yet they let us test on 700 megawatts of
their wind power capacity which is
equivalent to a large wind farm in the
United States this made them an
excellent proxy for external Wind Farm
operators
they also lent us an expert team to
advise on metrics and benchmarks and to
share the data that we needed
this is another critical component of AI
for the real world deployments working
with a domain expert team that can tell
you what they need how they need it to
work which constraints keep the system
safe what quantifiable metrics to use to
measure AI performance and how much
better that AI performance needs to be
than their previous systems to make the
cost of switching over even worth it and
that's just to name a few
so at this point we have our idea we
have our data we have our deployment
partner now to test and deploy our
system
improving the accuracy of electricity
Supply forecast is incredibly important
if predictions are higher than actual
generation renewable electricity
managers may not have enough Supply to
meet demand now this in turn drives the
purchase of carbon-intensive fossil
fuels to cover that Gap because they're
largely what makes up backup generation
now
the good news
our AI system performed 20 percent
better than Google's existing systems
even better news is that Google decided
to scale this technology and scaling is
so important
we will run out of time in the climate
countdown if we aren't deploying
solutions that are widely applicable
this particular solution is being
developed into a software product that
French company OMG is among the first to
Pilot
but you know it doesn't even take a
major research organization to do this
kind of work where we focused on AI for
supply side forecasting a small uk-based
non-profit called open climate fix is
focusing on AI for demand side
forecasting
they found a willing partner in the UK
National Grid and are currently
deploying forecasts that are two times
more accurate than the UK Grid's
previously used systems
now all of this is to say that AI can
help us with the transition to renewable
energy but scientists and technologists
we're not going to be able to do that
alone
we need to be working with partners and
experts who can teach us the how
so for those of you interested in this
space
if you're a domain expert
please share the problems you face and
the challenges that you have so that our
sector can ensure that AI Pursuits will
have impact in the real world and not be
purely academic
even better
if you want to incentivize ml
researchers to work on your problems
I'll let you in on a little secret
build a competition and they will come
sets of metrics
if you are you are a data holder
where it's safe and responsible to do so
please share data related to those
challenges
if you're not sure whether data you have
is even climate critical you can check
out climate change ai's website where
they have published a wish list of
climate critical data sets
access to these data sets would unblock
crucial research and innovation in AI
for climate
if you're a deployment partner
please let us know who you are
especially if you're willing to test
Innovative systems
and for everyone who's interested in
this space
please know you do not have to be
technical to work in Tech
AI for climate action requires a variety
of skill sets and a diversity of
backgrounds that yes includes research
scientists and Engineers but it also
includes ethicists and policy experts
communication teams product managers
program managers and so many more folks
now for the warning label
AI is not a silver bullet
it will not solve all problems driving
climate change it isn't even the right
tool for many of the challenges that we
face
AI is also not a technology without
tensions
it needs to be deployed safely and
responsibly
not to mention until our grids are run
on clean energy AI itself will carry a
carbon footprint as will any energy
intensive technology we use
but AI can be a transformational tool in
our fight against climate change it's
just on all of us to wield it
effectively
the why we need to is absolutely
harrowing the what we can do is really
exciting but it's the how we can do it
that will illuminate feasibility and
help us drive impact
so in your next climate action
conversations when someone presents you
with an exciting what please help the
advance the conversation to the
impactful how
thank you
[Applause]